if the pun is the lowest form of humor i guess
the practical joke is the oldest you'll agree
that most puns aren't very funny the same thing
goes for a big percentage of practical jokes
it's april fool's day and these boys think
they've dreamed up a killer little do they know
yeah a real killer very funny practical joke
what's the point of all this the point is
the handcuffs are just as tight and jail doors
just as hard to open whether you do something
deliberately or whether you didn't mean to once
you've been booked printed and your record is
in the police files statistically speaking you're
a member of that great brotherhood and sisterhood
the juvenile delinquents good intentions
aren't enough good sense is a lot more useful
yeah but isn't there a difference
between having a little fun and being bad
everybody wants some fun once in a while well sure
he does but there's a difference between good fun
and being stupid and careless or smart alec and
ignoring other people's right to enjoy life too
for instance take a look at these three
they don't really need anything the owner
of the store has for sale but did you
say something about having a little fun
it's a pretty old gag ethel needs
something way in the rear of the store
while she keeps the owner busy
the boys steal what they want that isn't really
stealing it isn't no sometime or other every kid
wants to swipe something just for the kick of it
you know probably something you don't even need
oh then that makes it all right eh it's only
stealing when you take something you need well
you see the owner doesn't know they don't really
need what they took he thinks they stole it
and since he paid money for his merchandise he
wants it back and he wants somebody punished
well he got both his wishes his
merchandise and somebody punished
and hank al and ethel got something
too brand new police records
they've got a lot of company in the juvenile
division files these are the records of
underage law breakers from just one large city
you're talking about these kids as if they were
criminals well what is a criminal somebody who
breaks the law if he does it often enough he's
a habitual criminal according to the fbi fifteen
percent of all arrests in this country are of
boys and girls under 21. every day miners
get involved with the law for the first time
usually just through thoughtlessness or
carelessness or being wild to go a bit
highbrow call it anti-social behavior in a typical
city a special division of the police department
with its own jail makes the first contact with
boys being boys but they remain here only a few
hours at most depending on the seriousness
of the complaint they are either discharged
or they are transferred to the juvenile hall under
jurisdiction of the juvenile court here the idea
is still not punishment but rather to set a boy or
girl back on the road to useful citizenship before
habit wildness can produce another community
burden another hardened habitual criminal
probation officers handle every delinquency case
is a separate problem like a doctor prescribing
treatment they try to restore the kind of
attitude that makes a normal right-thinking
boy or girl if they fail well there are jails
all over the country full of failures not only
probation officers failures but men and women
who failed themselves when they were growing up
yeah that's all swell but kids still have to have
some fun everybody's a little wild until they grow
up then they settle down that's very true but
there's a diff between being wild as you put it
and being a menace to the community when a boy
or girl reaches high school like ben and dave
here he's right at the age when he should start
learning some of the responsibilities that go
along with the privileges in a country like this
these boys are both from good homes both with good
school records but both as you say a little while
and they've just been invited to a halloween party
old stale trick and there
isn't enough excitement in it
then they let the air out of the tires of a few
cars that's pretty tame too but given credit
they're progressing the trouble is everything they
get away with makes ben and dave that much bolder
now they want to do something really good and
remember they're just a little wild ben notices
something about the car actually the owner
broke the law he left the keys in the car
it really isn't up to ben and dave to teach
him a lesson but if they decide to do it
it'll teach him a real one do what why steal
his car so it's happened this isn't small
change stuff anymore they've graduated into the
big leagues as the police say grand theft auto
of course they're thinking to themselves it
isn't really stealing they just borrow the car
they intend to bring it back to where
they found it it's just a halloween joke
they're getting bolder too driving a stolen pardon
me a borrowed car right into a drive-in stand
men's new idea was that they wouldn't have to pay
that even if the carhop took the license number
it would be traced not to ben and
dave but to the owner of the car
another joke well ben and dave don't know
it yet but their little joke is about over
you see in the meantime the
owner has reported his car stolen
and it was listed on the hot sheet the
patrol car spotted it in a few minutes
when ben and dave spied the police car they knew
they were really in a spot they knew they only
borrowed the car but the owner didn't and the
police didn't so they've made another mistake
trying to get away instead of surrendering
now as far as the police are concerned they
could be dangerous criminals and the officers
will take any measures necessary to get them
well that's it it started with a halloween joke
spiking the party punch and it ends with two boys
in jail did you read about it you see this is a
true story well that's all it takes you don't have
to be bad or some freak known as a delinquent
to get into trouble all it takes is stupidity
or carelessness or a disregard for other people's
rights sure you may get away with irresponsibility
and let somebody else carry your load for a while
but eventually it's going to catch up with you
and being young underage isn't going to be enough
of an alibi sometimes you're not in a position to
explain that you didn't mean it you know actually
we have it pretty special in the country like this
but everybody is expected to do his share if
he doesn't well society will take care of him
eventually whether he's just a wild kid or his
older brother or sister the habitual criminal
so don't take silly chances with your
own future it just isn't worth it